[Music]
today's question comes from rachel in
alaska my husband is a stay-at-home dad
and i work for a school district we
would like to flip our roles so he's the
provider and i stay at home with our
baby he recently passed an exam to
become an actuary and needs an
internship before an employer is willing
to look at his resume child care here is
non-existent with kova shutting
everything down internships don't pay as
much as i make from my job we own two
homes living in one and renting the
other i'm considering babysitting other
people's kids in our home while my
husband does an internship but there is
no guarantee my husband will find
employment afterwards and the income gap
would leave us unable to pay car
insurance
and buy groceries we currently have
twenty five hundred dollars in savings
and sixteen hundred dollars in our
checking no debt outside of the mortgage
can you offer any advice
in trying to make this transition
okay there's a whole lot of stuff here
uh just all over the place and i think
that we're focusing all on all of the
hurdles as opposed to maybe some of the
sacrifices we're going to have to make
that don't require us to sacrifice our
income but other types of sacrifices
the internship
how do we get the internship while he's
taking care of the kids uh we're gonna
have to make some sacrifices find a way
to come up with the money for the child
care for him to get that internship
that's where i would go first if the
internship is what is absolutely
necessary it is the gate if you will to
walk into this future to then get him
employed and you be able to switch to
the life that you want staying at home
then there are ways to find child care
for a season for him to get that
internship and it's just a function of
where there is a will there is a way an
old phrase but it's really true so
rachel um
the bible says how the abundance of the
heart the mouth speaks
and the language you're using of
absolutism
is inaccurate
and it says to me that you're a little
bit stuck in victim's side
and i want you to get out of that i want
you to rise above that and say okay
this is hard
but it's not impossible
okay let me give you an example of the
language i'm talking about
covert shutting everything down child
care here is non-existent
okay what you're saying is is that no
one in alaska keeps children
i'm sorry
it could be very difficult and it could
be very hard to find
and it might be a needle in a haystack
but completely non-existent is an
overstatement that's hyperbole you're
exaggerating
okay
we won't be able to buy groceries
not true
you buy groceries first
you might not be able to pay something
else
but you won't be able to maybe car
insurance i mean that might be down the
line down there but groceries are first
and you'll have the money for groceries
so that's drama
oh we're all going to starve to death
entered into your discussion here that
reveals where your head is on this
instead of trying to figure out a way to
do this you're throwing up as ken said
all the hurdles and all the barriers
that's what this thing drips of
as i read through it so here's the thing
this is going to be a tough season for
you guys
to make this transition it's not going
to be easy
uh he's gonna be working extra
delivering pizzas or doordash at night
and uh you're gonna be keeping kids
and you guys are gonna be living on
beans and rice and you're not gonna see
the inside of a restaurant and it's
gonna be really hard but you're to have
searched every single rock every timber
every tree that a child care provider
could have possibly hidden behind so you
can keep your job and you're going to go
do the impossible
because you are a victor not a victim
is it easy absolutely it's not easy
but it's but when you get the other side
of this five years from now and he has
that big job and you're able to be home
with the kids like your goal is and he's
able to be the actuary like his goal is
it will have been worth it when you look
back on it well the scary stuff that
she's talking about here is assuming
that she's going to walk away from her
very good and stable job in the school
district she's not going to do that you
know to your point he's going to go work
at night when she comes home and he's
going to go bust his tail where he's
going to come up with the money for
chuck i know but he's got to but he's
got to come up with the money for child
care yeah oh yeah yeah and then he goes
and in turn so you got to find someone
to keep them that's what she's saying
you find somebody yeah they're there
just keep working it i mean you're
talking to the church you you know you
you
if your life depended on it right you
could find somebody that's right but
there she's not going to lose her income
she's going to stay in that job while
he's in turn
and then then they get to make the
transition there you go that's it so um
let me tell you we always will
participate in something with you that
you're doing that's hard
we believe in doing stuff that's hard
that's worth it yeah we you know live
like no one else so later you can live
and give like no one else
but living like no one else is
impossible we're not going to line up
with that one we're going to tell you no
you still got to do it that's still how
it is it's still how we did it both ken
and i to get to be doing the things that
we do today and to get to be
uh who we are and and to have had the
successes that we've had in different
areas it's we've all paid a price and
sometimes it was an unbelievable tough
walk and it was hard and it was scary uh
but all we can ever tell you ken or me
about anything we're talking to you
about is if you do that
it's worth it the other side of the
rainbow it's there it's worth it go do